[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers actual viewers try to find
mistakes on our show we've been doing
this since this show premiered so far
many many many challengers no winners
you'd think they would stop no you think
they'd give up at a certain point
because we don't make mistakes it just
doesn't happen
yeah well tonight is a bit unusual okay
this is because usually I say something
and one fan picks up riot this is
different this one literally dozens and
dozens of fans think they caught a
mistake and they say it happened to
during a recent monologue hello Conan
House is watching your opening monologue
no show where you talk about Marvel and
then you did an incredible hulk
impression
you said the hulk was a member of the
Fantastic Four Marvel Comics is updating
the Fantastic Four to give the heroes
things like smartphones and iPads yeah
yes so now when the Hulk gets mad he
rips his shirt and shouts Hulk send
angry text problem that is where you
made your mistake because ball was never
part of because he's not that's why your
audience really wasn't laughing I feel
like
members of the Fantastic Four it's mr.
fantastic the miserable woman Human
Torch and the thing a picture of them
right here a simple mistake anyone
could've made it but it seems like you
made an error to me this nerd just made
chummy by the maestro
really piss me off
[Applause]
everybody's thinking the same thing
we've got Conan this time finally that
laughing feminine redhead we've got him
cornered got him right where we want him
unfortunately you don't you see all of
you are dead wrong when I said the Hulk
was in the Fantastic Four I was not
referring to the Hulk that you are all
thinking of check out this footage from
the Fantastic Four animated series
you'll see what I'm talking about well
gang looks like the five of us have
saved the world again five of us we're
the Fantastic Four you're forgetting
about the Hulk
you know my penis is pretty incredible
there's a reason they call you mr.
fantastic
and there's something else I should
mention the hope that you guys are
thinking of even he was the member of
the Fantastic Four for three issues back
in the early 1990s here's the cover of
Fantastic Four number 348 that is a real
cover get in there nice and close there
he is okay the Hulk got around ladies
and gentlemen he didn't just appear
there he was also a member of the world
champion 1980 Philadelphia Phillies look
you people know that he was a board
member of Proctor and Gamble
alright and for a brief time in the late
80s hook was an official member of the
Blue Man Group which is very
[Applause]
[Music]
now there's one more thing I have to say
regarding my supposed Hulk mistake which
has now been cleared up it wasn't a
mistake it was a trap
you see I planted that hook reference in
the monologue to draw out our very
nerdiest fans why do you ask would I do
such a thing
behold I've been keeping this cage this
cage of jocks in our studio for days
driving them wild with the scent of nerd
from an old Captain America t-shirt that
hasn't been watched since comic-con 2011
these jocks are starving for nerd meat
thanks to the Lance rules at YouTube
they now know where each and every one
of you lives release the jocks
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right to your home the doorbell
should just give me a minute please
a second the doorbell should be ringing
anything in it now all right ladies and
gentlemen the challenge still stands if
you think you spotted an error on our
show report a team koco.com / haha I
found an error we will sort it out here
on there